when you look at the most intelligent
and mechanically gifted players in
esports it's easy to see that they all
sort of have one thing in common it's
not that they all look good hoisting
silverware or that they routinely
produce highlights that make us question
a reality no it's that the way they
carry themselves in game often mirrors
how they act outside of it they're cool
they're calm and they're seemingly
always collected they're always in
control no matter the situation and can
be relied upon even when the odds are
stacked against them great read from
zeus to hold off as well because he knew
ct was coming so the event was nest life
left nes likely i should say what a shot
for guardian words out of my mouth as he
nails it through the box he is tagged up
smoke on the bomb immediately he's got
the kit doesn't elect to hold on to it
yet he's got time to play with
two for two smoke will do it's phased to
the final and guardian is an absolute
god of course we all love those trash
talkers who can add some much needed
spice to our favorite competitive games
but there is a correlation between
professionalism
and success and often it's those who
show humility that conquer gaming's
biggest challenges looks like ning is
looking for a flank that's the curtain
call they're pinned into a narrow
corridor look at the damages it comes
across ning looks for entry they found
shintai once again he goes golden but a
travel kill for rookie he lands the
paddle start burst and finds the
lollipop that being said there are
exceptions to the rule and perhaps no
one embodies that more than tyler tyler1
steinkamp the misunderstood misanthropic
manlet who recently hit challenger rank
in all five roles in league of legends
oh my god oh my god
how has this seemingly meat-headed
beefed-up egomaniac become the only
person to complete league's most
difficult journey on stream
i'm built so different it's crazy
and what if tyler1 is
in fact not all of the things that he
portrays himself to be what if in spite
of all his outwardly outlandish behavior
he's actually one of the most galaxy
brained solo queue players league has
ever seen
look at us
it's done it's over i am officially
have gotten challenger on every
single
role
[Music]
okay so i think that by now most of you
are probably aware of the fact that
tyler1 has become something of a
mainstay on this channel he's the
rageaholic once permabanned draven
cosplayer who has
somehow become the poster boy of league
of legends i say somehow because tyler
wasn't exactly known for being the most
positive influence on the community
would you smite it full hp new you
stupid
can't get it
holy trash
holy [ __ ] yes tyler was once very very
toxic but to his credit he has made
significant progress over the years with
many claiming that he's been reformed at
times
that remains
up for debate
look at this
look a scoreboard
[Music]
you can't do anything
shut the [ __ ] up
but what is clear is that in spite of
this dulling down tyler has never lost
his competitive edge you see by trade t1
is an ad carry and a pretty good one at
that
his draven is quite frankly disgusting
and according to him has been challenger
level his whole god damn life
oh my god i'm the greatest alive
however adc is often seen as one of the
mindless roles in the game you get
babysat by a support while in lane and
as long as you have the right items and
stand behind your team and right-click
people
you can be unstoppable anyway after
spending years grinding in league's solo
queue gulag
tyler had developed a bit of an ire
towards
one position in particular
junglers partly because he felt that
junglers were always complaining about
how difficult their job is
which he
obviously
disagreed with i'm gonna save the custom
to the end right but i'll tell you this
jungle is the easiest role in the game
and it's not even close all these
junglers you see that they say oh
i'm sorry my mustache
i know this is a struggle for you that
say that it's hard you know my laners
they're bad
so in 2020 tyler had had enough of
jungler's bellyaching and made it his
life's mission to prove that they had
the easiest role in the game by making
it to challenger on a fresh account
although in the beginning it did prove
to be a tougher task than he'd
originally anticipated
hello
flash ignite
all right i gotta play for myself all
right it's doomed never mind i'll just
do it myself
you broke an ass champion what is this
what
what
[ __ ] hello tyler one
despite tyler's initial hypothesis that
junglers were in fact
little [ __ ] he soon came to realize
that the role was actually a lot more
nuanced than he'd first suspected
first off when you're playing at a high
elo you need to have near perfect
pathing on top of that you need to
manage your presence in three different
lanes and if anything bad happens to
your team ever
you can bet your ass that you're the one
who's gonna be blamed for it and even
though his naysayers were being
vindicated by his failings
tyler refused to give up
no instead he kept grinding and over
time got better he even recruited tarzan
a notoriously toxic streamer and
challenger ranked junglemain as his
coach
which
was helpful
most of the time try to get the crap i
don't know it's like
dusty peter
okay not bad
drink your pods yep cocoon
generally
[Music]
can you shut the [ __ ] up
i can't focus
i can't see anything it's too laggy then
in may of 2020 over
1800 games later
he finally did it he became the first
person to smite their way to challenger
solely out of spite
i did
what's up yo what's up tina
i'm the greatest of all time
tyler proved all the haters wrong and
those who bet on him failing
had to put their money where their mouth
was but tyler wasn't done this success
opened up a new opportunity like sure
tyler knew that he was the best but
wouldn't it be easier if he could just
shut everybody else up
by proving it so that's when tyler1 got
the bright idea to embark on a quest
that would make his skills on the rift
undeniable he set his sights on hitting
challenger in all the remaining roles
and his next stop would be the top lane
now for all of the non-league fluent
people watching this video
top lane is largely considered to be one
of the hardest positions to play in solo
queue it feels like you're playing the
game on an island
and when you're paired with randoms that
feeling only becomes more apparent
making matters worse tyler1 unwittingly
undertook his top lane challenge during
a season where it was one of the weaker
positions so he was definitely feeling
the pain but to his credits just like
before
tyler1
persevered and just like with jungle
after making a few adjustments within no
time he was tearing it up
[Music]
[ __ ]
well
i'd have to say that's uh that's uh
stopgap
[Music]
after a grueling 2600 plus games on his
top lane account tyler1 hits challenger
in july of 2021.
it's done
at this point tyler had climbed the
steepest mountains in league and he
hadn't brute forced his way to the top
on mechanical ability alone as it turns
out there was a method to his madness in
that he picked smart champions that
worked with his playstyle like ivorn for
jungle and cho'gath for top characters
that allowed him to focus on map
awareness and decision making of course
that's not to say that every once in a
while the man didn't just lock in irelia
just to remind the kitties who they were
messing with oh [ __ ] that's that's
anyway after completing his top lane
journey tyler was more than halfway
through his quest
so he set his sights
on the mid lane now tyler1 was poised to
do well with this one i mean think about
it he's powell's with the greatest mid
laner of all time like if the guy ever
needed some tips he was set that said
mid
did pose some challenges
to start it's probably the most
mechanically difficult role in the game
thanks to its wide pool of challenging
champions plus its centralized position
in the map makes mid vulnerable to ganks
from all angles but on the flip side
thanks to his mechanical chops as an adc
and the experience he developed roaming
as a jungler tyler1 was able to adapt to
mid relatively easy
oh yeah he's mad
oh yeah he's madness
oh
you're so lucky i'm the greatest
to everyone other than himself
tyler1 not only reached challenger in
660 games but he managed to do it in the
same season that he hit challenger in
top lane
how
because
you that's how
mid yeah
it's the mammoth man
[ __ ]
and it was easy at this point no one
could deny t1 skill and even
accomplished pro players were starting
to chime in on his progress yeah i i
think tyler is probably super
knowledgeable now that he's played more
than 80 carry i mean he played mid and
top so he's wait and jungle right so he
did it and he's done every role except
for support so i'm not surprised he has
better game knowledge after that after
getting his mid lane account to
challenger all that was left between t1
and eternal bragging rights was support
the most selfless role in the game but
the strange thing is that it actually
ended up being the easiest one for him
to master his map awareness had improved
considerably from his time spent in the
jungle and thanks to his countless hours
molding as an 80 carry he knew what was
expected of him when playing support
wait for my engineer
oh my
god let's go bro
yeah tell me i'm not the greatest alive
bro oh my god
what are you doing
then on february 19th 2022
it finally happened after a meager
443 games tyler1 completed his support
challenge
thus becoming the first person to reach
challenger in all five roles on the
stream we started with jungle it took us
2 000
games
3 000 almost top lane about the same mid
900 support quizzes officially what is
this
242
and 201 what is that
43
gabe's and i've been 80 carry charter my
entire goddamn
life bro
and it's done
officially done
i am a
problem
across three years over 4 600 games and
a metric ton of [ __ ] talk later tyler1
had proven that he was indeed built diff
and no one could deny his skill but more
importantly no one could diminish his
hard work at the end of the day most
pros can reach challenger no problem
most could probably even do it in all
five roles if they really wanted to but
to do it on fresh accounts as a
non-competitor and no life it on stream
[Music]
that takes something special no one
except for maybe tyler1 himself is
saying that he's the greatest solo queue
player of all time but his patience and
dedication has to be respected and sure
he may have lost his mind along the way
but by chronicling his epic undertaking
daily he brought in thousands upon
thousands of onlookers who wanted to see
if he could prove them wrong and that's
exactly what he did so he played 1700
games and then he hit challenger so i
mean kudos he like literally grinded so
hard
and he improved so much that he managed
to make it from diamond one to
challenger level skill
so i have no doubt that he earned it
hell even t1's most fabled nemesis riot
games sent him a gift to commemorate his
incredible achievement i kind of like it
dude i like it
it's special it's unique you know what
i'll say thank you riot that's the day
you better
riot games you better flip this you
better save it because i will not say it
again ever in my life
i appreciate it thank you guys
but
i am the goddamn greatest of all time so
again hey
i mean i deserve this to be honest
so
the question lingers
what's next for league's solo queue
conqueror well as of right now he's set
his sights on a new challenge hitting
rank 1 as a support and honestly with
what he's been able to do up to this
point
who are we to say that he won't do just
that
maybe after this whole ordeal tyler has
reformed even more maybe he's learned
some humility and after becoming
intimately familiar with the pains
inherent to each role and walking the
rift in their shoes has developed a
better understanding
of what it means to be a team player
there you go
one one one level eleven one one one one
one you wanna know why because i'm
number one that's why
now the jury might still be out on that
one but regardless tyler proved all his
haters wrong
i can't believe i'm saying this on
camera in earnest
but the proof
is in the pudding tyler1 is just a
different breed than the rest of us
love him or hate him this dude has truly
walked the walk like no one ever has
call him a demon all you want he has at
the very least earned the right for you
to slap ranked in front of it hey l l l
ll
darius l
riot sucks
l
better jungle wins
good job katarina jungle diff
riot l
at darius
capital
l
hey hold this hold this wait let me find
it
oh
found it
l
let's go
honestly i get why dude
like when i watch myself jungle i
totally understand why if i if if like
if i can save my mid laners life
i or get or secure them a kill totally
like we'll totally do it if it [ __ ]
with my pathing
it's unlikely
[Music]